hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
I finally did it I managed to get all
this stuff for the event of course with
some little help but we'll talk about
that in a second but yeah we're gonna be
showing off today the mask outfit for
all four of the factions we're gonna be
showing off the battle outfit what
you're gonna be expecting the ornament
the idol effect the emote effects the
execution effect and all 24 weapons for
every character in the game so that
everybody knows what weapon they want
and what weapon to get and what it looks
like and even if it's worth grinding I
couldn't have done this without some
help one of my friends in my discord
blues Ike he's also another youtuber he
ended up getting 13 of the 24 characters
well I got the remaining 11 so go to his
channel go to his newest video it's in
the description down below and just say
thanks from gingy I would be highly
appreciate if you guys check him out on
get on screen right now you're seeing
some of his gameplay on his channel
excellent youtuber definitely go check
him out but definitely go send him some
thanks and subscribe to his channel yeah
with that like TV if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new my Twitter and
discord will be in the description down
below and this is also the outro so my
two most recent videos are gonna be
popping up on the screen at the end of
this there will be timestamps in the
description but with that peace out let
me know your favorite weapon or item in
the comments below and I'll see you guys
peace out
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]